já a previsão é que sabe que o poeta
nenhum
o lado diz que sua alta que quem fala é
o dar preciso muito em 2011 é mais um
vídeo e os estragos de que mais um
episódio da nossa série the fight night
é fredes e hoje pessoal nós vamos
finalmente consegui passar a quinta
noite eu de que finalmente por conteúdo
tentei duas vezes e não consegui
ok pessoal com estarmos aqui quinta
noite eo neste início vou fazer
exatamente o que vocês me recomendaram
que é ficar atento apenas as portas e as
luzes e não gastar muita bateria neste
início para depois a partir de 3 4 da
manhã eu começar então usar realmente as
câmeras não sei deixe me só estáveis a
raposa só quem está lá os raposas aberto
e ouvem ou lêem também ok também não vem
só eu vim aqui está aberto que está
aberto a quem eu vou fechar a porta eu
vou fechar a porta por onde pode ser
assim que volta não é
pode ser que eu volte deixe sua vida que
curte né
vocês precisam salvar se estranha razão
obrigado mesmo hockey ficar atenta às
portas e as luzes no início é ok
deixem só confirmar seus já voltou para
lá pronto já está o lifting e agora
vamos show explorar pessoal esperar até
que sejam três da manhã e partir daí sim
nós ficamos mais atentos às câmeras
ok luz nada luz nada pronto
só espero que esta estratégia resulta
mesmo e alguns de vocês já têm disseram
que existe uma sexta e sétima noite e
não tenha certeza existe porque não pode
ser de quinta não é mas se houver eu
estou e sabe o meu pouco equipamento
estava seguinte já em cima de uma sexta
uma sétima não é
mas pronto está próxima de touré os sete
dias só quem transporta também hoje
quinta é segunda não a segunda deu seu
quarto é hoje a quinta porque à noite
cinco supostamente viajado perdi meu não
ok para identificar os grupos anúncio
um estudo conduzido bem
não não é um samba rock pessoal estamos
aqui outra vez e agora eu vou estar
ainda mais atento às portas não é
obrigado a manter sempre as portas
fechadas é isso
ok deixando só confirmar sua serra pousa
frontal e senhora aqui
o pato está ali só falta mesmo com ele
mas pronto não vou ficar atento às
câmeras
eu vou ficar aqui olhava pro outro à
esquerda e à direita caiu os selos não
estender ao fechar a porta é isso
será isso que eu fiz de errado a pouco
eu não fechei a porta quando algo não
funcionava e foi por isso que o bicho um
salto em cima lá fica mais que a outra
porque
deixe me só vida pessoal você deixe me
só veio aqui perto no quarto
aqui o parto deve estar mais atento
diário digital é e ascendem assim mesmo
o uso por isso vamos ficar aqui rocha de
20 anos a bateria 89% que é muito não é
não é preocupante
para já não passa aqui não houve um
passo aqui
o parque é vento e neve entre a tentar
andar passo rímel
a gente escuta
vamos atacar e pisa amigo
o fitei fechada aeroporto nenhum só
seria não dar lucro se passar desta
quinta à noite não dá não dá não dá não
dá não dá
está aqui tranquilo tranquilo
moita vamos lá passa por uma da manhã
rápido rápido rápido a sorrir meu ok tá
ali tranqüilo e pronto e agora vou ficar
aqui só ver luzes só havia shakilus vez
em quando para tentar um auxílio que
calma calma não não espero tal lhe
faltar nem no escuro também malandrão na
coxa não conseguiu fechar não não vou
mais estável
assim não dá
o sol é vossa estratégia não está a
resultar eu não sei o que costumo fazer
errado eu não sei se era exatamente
assim que vocês querem que eu faça mas
não dá não dá só mandar eu não consigo
não consigo tem que usar as câmeras
obrigatoriamente eu vou ter que usar as
câmeras porque não a mãe muitos pegam
logo ensino na honda só não dá
como é que é possível ficar a lei tanto
tempo será que eu espero que o vai já na
câmara assim eu ser embora ainda em 2000
como é que é possível resgatar que não
pode ser assim não pode e não pode estar
aqui há muita pressão procuração só duas
da manhã já sei o pronto-socorro douro
ali o pato não está o uso de falsas taxa
perto oque eu tenho que ter atenção
mesmo estúdio eu acho que este sim é que
é o fred eu acho
ou seja isto é mais perigoso deus topo o
jogo criando apanharam vai ter que estar
aqui esta câmara mais tarde ou mais cedo
a não o era o pato era o pato cavalo
está em alerta
mas pronto quando quando fred estiver
mesmo ao pé da câmara eu vou fechar a
porta do sol
logo logo ficará pouco tempo já está
preocupa tanto aqui perto
já se foi embora não esteja no urso
estava bater à porta a porta ainda bem
que eu cheguei aqui importa agora vamos
pra que ele vai embora é claro 30 que
quebra perdeu se afastar é isso mesmo
pessoal já 63 deles foi quando eu estou
à porta tem filhos câmeras para se
afastarem é colocado - não não falava lá
não não não
edson ali do outro o meu benfica teve um
lado do outro lado do painel fica
testado na prainha e não seja pessoal
acho que tu ir bem agora eu vou ter que
olhar para a câmera dele eu acho que ou
se vai embora daqui
não acho que não é isso eu acho que não
é isso que está aqui está aqui vou
fechar a porta também duas portas
fechadas já se foi embora
a raposa está onde está quieto a cair 3
da manhã ontem na minha volta de 3 horas
de jogo
você percebeu é que você tem no botão é
um pai tem um chamado à terra pelos é
que foi
mas a alegria pessoal pela primeira vez
neste jogo estou a sentir a alegria por
estar aqui dentro eu estar aqui hoje eu
vou fechar a porta e nem quando nem
porta fechada acaba está aqui a não ser
que eu venha por aqui também não
meu pai que mora por isso o senhor ou
deixem passar a marca comercial já
então tá aqui eu sou briga para provar
entre as mãos em seu país também olhar
pra mim esta memória pra mim
eu não vou deixar tomate agora vai ficar
à porta fechada tendo tido embora aí e
gostou
não vamos ter uma boa trilha com quatro
da manhã e só quatro da manhã e sub-14
feminino
já fui não já fui já estava à espera
também traz perna
eu acho que consegui passar eu acho que
consegui passar por favor diga que eu
passar e quinta à noite o jato que é uma
hora a pessoa a uma hora meu tempo
consegui por favor por favor do espaço
ai meu deus eu digo que eu passei eu
acho que é um negócio que não acho que
eu vá apanhar apanhar o vovô não fique
tanto tempo lá e conseguir falou tive
que o marrone cujo jobs esporte see e
honesto e ian crocker só eu estava em
117 desconto ou o sentimento ao acordar
sem perceber ele sair eu não quer saber
de se tornava eu sei que passei pessoal
eu finalmente passar a quinta noite sem
interno
ok só vocês tinham razão final a uma
cesta o vai ter uns que dizem nunca vi
uma sétima mas pronto e já não era muito
surpresa pra mim eu tive aqui uma uma
hora e tal é tentar passar a quinta
noite de quinta noite imagina agora está
aí é sétima salvar uma sétima realmente
pronto pessoal já sabe
deixem o vosso apoio voz flick favorita
série fala porém muito este vídeo porque
eu tive aqui muito tempo eu jogar esta
porcaria salvar muitos sustos e
produtivo dar muitos cortes porque o
vídeo não pode ficar de uma hora não é
mas eis então pessoal eu vou tentar com
vida e sai ainda hoje na quinta eu acho
que hoje quinta mas eis que só sabem
deixa o vosso pai que foi bonito fica em
banho de a próxima